if you're an anime fan then you should
know that on the 7th of April one of the
best New Gen series is about to drop on
Crunchyroll Marshall is the perfect
mixture between one punch Man Black
Clover and Harry Potter and it has a
great cast Amazing World building and a
ton of mystery as well the series senses
around Mash who's a guy living in a
magical world who relies on his muscles
alone to survive after a bizarre series
of events the magicless match is
suddenly forced to attend the best magic
school in the country with the goal of
becoming its top student on my channel I
did a full rundown of all the reasons
you need to check the show out so click
the link down below if you want to know
why this could be your next favorite
series